maintenant maintenant à cette première
médicale mondiale à lyon hier l'équipe
du professeur dubernard à greffer les
deux mains et les deux avant-bras un
homme de 33 ans qui avait été amputée
après l'explosion d'une fusée artisanale
une opération particulièrement
méticuleuse qui a nécessité
l'intervention simultanée de dix huit
chirurgiens benoît gadret jean claude
martin ils attendaient désespérément ces
nouvelles mains depuis quatre ans
maintenant
depuis que l'explosion d'une fusée
artisanale la priver de ces deux organes
ce patient est un français peintre en
bâtiment père de deux enfants il a reçu
les deux mains d'un donneur anonyme
l'opération a duré 17 heures elle a
nécessité la présence de 50 personnes
dont dix huit chirurgiens est une
intervention très minutieuse sur le plan
de la chirurgie mais l'acte chirurgical
n'est qu'un des aspects de ce type
de deux heures centre du procédé bien
entendu l'immunosuppression et la
prévention du rejet sont l'essentiel de
ce type de transplantation
cette main anonyme est la première créée
il ya maintenant 16 mois
depuis ce patient australien a retrouvé
une sensibilité au bout du doigt
il parvient même à écrire mais cet
exploit médical sans précédent à une
contrepartie un traitement anti rejet
très lourd avec un risque à terme de
maladies graves
le remède n'est-il pas pire que le mal
c'est la raison pour laquelle le comité
d'éthique a demandé à l'équipe lyonnaise
de limiter les greffes ou personne
amputée des deux mains un handicap si
lourd qu'il justifie la prise de risque
ça reste une chirurgie d'exception ne
faut pas absolument pas banaliser cet
acte chirurgical qui est un halak de
lure qui est lourd par le traitement au
quotidien lourd par les complications du
traitement immuno suppresseurs et il
faut que le patient soit informée car il
ya risque d'altérer son espérance de vie
l'équipe du professeur dubernard devrait
à titre expérimental réalisé 5 grève des
deux mains dans les deux années à venir
pour l'instant le patient opéré se porte
bien mais ce n'est que dans deux ou
trois ans que l'on pourra juger de
l'opportunité ou non de ce type
d'opération